on va parler des gilet jaune maintenant
d'abord avant de voir notre reportage à
la rencontre des gilet jaune aujourd'hui
on vous parle des gilets jaunes est ce
que ce terme recouvre en réalité des
réalité complètement différente
emmanuelle anizon les gilet jaune
ce sont d'abord des gens qui sont réunis
par une même défiance défiance vis-à-vis
des institutions défiance vis-à-vis de
la classe supérieure défiance vis-à-vis
de tout ce qui au fond représente une
forme de pouvoir et et de
de société qui va bien face à une
société qui
a du mal à survivre alors évidemment
après au sein de cette sociologie de 7
il ya des gens différents il ya des gars
des mamans soeur et des retraités il ya
des jeunes filles et des artisans mais
mais globalement ils sont quand même
très très homogène sur 7 sur 7 sur cette
défiance dans leur vote mais moi j'ai
été étonné là pendant cette élection de
voir à quel point il y avait par un peu
une homogénéité et fat montrait même
autour de mélenchon c'est un premier
tour beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'entre
eux enverront voter mélenchon dont
certains qui avaient voté rassemblement
enfin le pen sacrant auparavant fin
celle que ce qui est
complètement complètement
d'ailleurs quand on dit qu'il ya une
difficulté à rassembler une marine le
pen d'à côté eric zemmour de l'autre
comme vous le soulignez tout à l'heure
c'est aussi parce que sociologiquement
ce sont de france et on a vu à quel
point ces deux france la france d'en
haut et la france d'en bas avaient enfin
c'est cette facture s'était renforcée
notamment avec la crise sanitaire qui a
beaucoup polarisé donc
même pas à part la crise sanitaire
justement et à la gestion du vaccin et à
cette défiance aussi sur ce qu'on veut
nous injecter enfin on a retrouvé cette
cette union la celle et gilet jaune qui
skie qui ont fait finalement cause
commune avec eux les antilles passé les
anti vaccins et justement il ya trois
ans et demi un cette colère des gilet
jaune explosé dans toute la france
notamment à cause de l'augmentation des
prix du carburant aujourd'hui le litre
d'essence pour les 10 les deux euros
quel est l'état d'esprit de ces gilet
jaune aujourd'hui et 4000 du quinquennat
d'emmanuel mâcon samia de chair est allé
à leur rencontre à fumer dans les
ardennes
c'était leur quartier général
les gilets jaunes ont occupé la place
centrale de fumer pendant plus de quatre
mois
quétier guicherd faisait partie du noyau
dur elle qui n'avait pourtant jamais
manifesté mon premier gilet jaune edat
de 17 novembre 2018 je les gardais parce
que je suis toujours gilet jaune
même si à plus de yapi le sujet même si
à plus de manifestations à l'heure
actuelle ici je le garde parce que oui
c'est no koi une mobilisation dont elle
garde un souvenir ému mais aussi un peu
amer le grand débat qui est suivi n'a
pas apporté les changements qu'elle
espérait dès le départ on savait que
c'était d'enfumage plutôt contre on
s'aperçoit on n'en parle plus du grand
débat où sont nos claviers d'audience
enfin
y a rien après ça y'a rien quoi
tout était parti de la taxe carbone sur
les carburants à l'époque le litre
d'essence était un peu moins d'un euro
cinquante trois ans et demi plus tard il
frôle les 2 euros 1 85
kg
et 29 litres 26 litres pardon ça fait 50
euros avant avec 50 euros on avait moi
j'avais le plein quoi fonction une
petite voiture c'est une saxo on
retrouve son contrôle technique et
pigeons pressent contre telle ou telle
pasqua pasco contre bon
contrôle pour pollution c'est pas grave
je roulerai avec ma voiture comme ça et
puis c'est tout et des domiciles katia
du jer passe beaucoup de temps sur les
routes chaque mois il faut compter 300 à
350 euros de carburant pour les deux
voitures de la famille trop pour son
budget
avec son mari ils touchent de 1200 euros
à eux deux et ont trois enfants à charge
tous les deux en même temps on pourra
pas partir ça nous aurait fait du bien
mais on se rabat on ne saurait pas
partir
c'est tout peut-être planté temps dans
le jardin puis faire du camping à la
maison
c'est comme ça
sa valise pour notre reportage katia
gougères a invité ses anciens camarades
gilet jaune donc ça fait un moment qu'on
s'est pas vu
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se sont
passées quand même depuis
l'excellent magro
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle certains goûtent et jean
luc mélenchon dont sous marine le pen
aucun n'a voté emmanuel macron au second
tour le quinqua damas rougeâtre en plus
rien il ya trois ans j'étais un peu
sceptique j'ai dit oui peut-être que
mais là j'attends plus rien parce que en
fait on s'aperçut pendant cinq ans et
l'art est un très bon joueur boit pas ce
qu'il a été ni 50 plus qui va faire
encore quelque chose comme tous les
mouvements sociaux celui des gilet jaune
s'est peu à peu éteint mais la colère
elle est toujours l'un celle des fins de
mois de plus en plus difficile bonjour
je vends que j'attends ça redémarre mais
comment
grosse majorité des gilet jaune que qui
étaient avec nous quand tu leur pose la
question et répondent banon
j'ai donné je laisserais faire les
autres et je peux le comprendre je peux
comprendre que tu as essayé ça n'a pas
marché donc forcément t'as plus envie
d'y retourner j'ai du mal à croire pour
sortir
et si ça l'a fait wayne serait le
premier à sortir c'est clair tous rêvent
d'une nouvelle mobilisation de grande
ampleur sans oser y croire vraiment
beaucoup de choses dans ce reportage de
celles de cheikh d'abord on l'entend
aujourd'hui cette dame gilet jaune qui
fait son plein qui dit qu'elle en a 300
350 euros de carburant par mois qu'elle
peut pas prendre de vacances on sent
chez eux à la fois une forme de
lassitude et peut-être une forme de
résignation par rapport à leur situation
actuelle est ce que c'est ça aussi qu'on
ressente emmanuel quand vous allez à
leur rencontre il est très bien ce
reportage parce que d'abord écrit qu'un
de caricatures pas et il montre bien la
réalité en fait de deux de ces personnes
qui sont à 5 euros près chaque mois en
fait sur leur budget et qui comme
beaucoup effectivement vivre en
périphérie ville sont obligés de se
déplacer consomme donc du carburant et
sont très impactées par la hausse des
prix à une amende ils n'ont rien gagné
donc oui ils sont ils sont un peu
ils sont très fatigués ils sont un peu
désespéré finalement puisque ce
carburant fins cette essence qui était
un sacré antique aujourd'hui et à 2
euros
devrait les faire ressortir dans la rue
sauf que beaucoup sont beaucoup sortie
est donc parfois payer très cher dans la
vie professionnelle vie privée est
aujourd'hui en moi je on semblait qu'ils
sont à s'épuiser ils n'ont pas envie de
refaire ce combat de rue qui a été très
éprouvant qui n'a mené à pas grand chose
et en même temps cette colère elle est
là cette amertume elle est là donc ya
pas de résignation vraiment moi je
n'emploierai pas ce terme il ya une
fatigue il ya un épuisement et en même
temps comme le dit très bien le monsieur
dans le reportage ci d'autres
repartaient à la charge bah moi j'irai
et ça c'est très marrant parce que ce
qui est encore sur le terrain là ces
dernières semaines j'ai passé les tours
d2 des élections présentiel avec eux les
dimanches d2 dès dimanche soir et à
chaque fois il me disait non mais moi je
reste on arrête et puis oui enfin on va
quand même à république et puis on va
car voilà et c'est à dire que il ya la
fois ce ras-le-bol de nostalgie aussi de
ce qui est sûrement il ya une nostalgie
parce que où vous le voyez là il ya une
chaleur il y avait une humanité en fait
dans ce mouvement c'est des gens qui
étaient souvent un peu les uns à sa
seule finalement dans leur petite maison
un peu à travailler à retrouver dans
leur petit pavillon et la sociale sur
les ronds présent créer du lien social
ils ont eu conscience qu'il représentait
une forme de groupes de force évidemment
parce qu'il ya eu aussi une ivresse de
deux de ces manifestations qui faisait
un peu trembler la france et le pouvoir
il ya une amertume parce que parce que
elle parle du cahier de doléances elle
parle du grand débat de fait ces cahiers
qui devait être numérisés
j'ai amené à plein de propositions et
des échanges n'ont rien donné il y a il
il ya eu quasiment aucune écoute un
pouvoir sur sur sur ce mouvement
ce qui est intéressant dans ce mouvement
aussi c'est qu'il ya une prise de
conscience politique de ces de ce groupe
cette université à celles ouvertes et
gilet jaune pour pour donc l'idée aussi
d'une
politique plus participative pour les
citoyens du riq du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne de ces questions
de de participation des citoyens elle
est entrée chez eux aujourd'hui il ya
une vraie attente politique et il ya
aussi une vraie attente sur des
questions concrètes notamment la
question du pouvoir d'achat quand on va
avoir avec vous hier évidemment le
gouvernement a tenté d'apporter des
réponses en tout cas il a dit qu'il
allait le faire après législatif six
survivants noire conduite mais voilà
alors pendant un temps mais bon on avait
compris que les mesures seraient prises
dès maintenant avant les élections
législatives afin d'occuper le terrain
social on l'a vu avec aussi cette
campagne à gauche qui s'intensifie alors
finalement le bouquet de mesures sera
présenté dans la foulée je cite des
élections pour être adopté très
rapidement a dit gabriel attal le porte
parole du gouvernement cité thiers à
l'issue du dernier conseil des ministres
du quinquennat ce dont j'ai connaissance
ce qui a été présenté ce matin par bruno
le maire et olivier du soft en conseil
des ministres c'est les grandes
orientations d'un projet de loi de
finances rectificative qui sera présenté
dans la foulée des élections
législatives et les engagements que j'ai
évoqué les mesures que j'ai évoquées
figureront dans ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative allez on commence
l'inventaire à la prévert oriane de
toutes les mesures qui ont été annoncées
par exemple on voit la prolongation du
bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz et
l'électricité jusqu'à la fin 2022 un
nouveau dispositif je cite pérenne et
mieux ciblés pour la remise la ristourne
carburant de 15 à 18 centimes pour les
salariés la prime macron sera triplée 1
c'est donc ça concerne les salariés
gagnant jusqu'à 3 fois le smic on
continue deuxième animation le
gouvernement a annoncé la baisse des
charges pour les indépendants la reçoit
représentera jusqu'à 550 euros de gains
de pouvoir d'achat a dit hier gabriel
attal 550 euros par an pour les
fonctionnaires le point d'indicé sera
dégelé les retraites et prestations
sociales revalorisé au 1er juillet sans
attendre le calendrier habituel chèques
alimentaires lancé cet été avec des
produits alimentaires que l'on veut
apparemment locaux durables voire bio a
également dit le porte parole du
gouvernement dans les points la
suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle une manière je cite de
baisser les impôts a dit exécutif est-ce
que ça emmanuelle anizon ça peut être
une réponse aux attentes des gilets
jaunes ou est ce qu'ils attendent autre
chose alors c'est en partie une réponse
et je pense que c'est absolument
nécessaire enfin tout ce qui pourra
aider le pouvoir d'achat de deux bases
pour c'est vraiment
absolument nécessaire bien sûr ça
suffira pas ça suffira pas en tout cas à
réconcilier les citoyens avec
le système politique et et ses
représentants il y à il y a un travail
mais de fond et on a vu cette défiance
encan s'exprimer pendant la crise
sanitaire tellement forte on voit aussi
ce complotisme se développer de manière
tellement fort voilà donc la réponse
démocratique elle est beaucoup plus
profond de pub large que ça la n 12
cette phrase qui est assez marquante
avec le vote des manuels macron s'est
fait entuber encore une fois est de
toute façon n'en attend rien c'est le
symbole de cette fracture démocratique
aujourd'hui ah oui je l'avais au delà de
la personne d'emmanuel m'avait bien sûr
bien sûr il ya une une haine on va le
dire comme ça en tout cas vis-à-vis des
lettres des manuels macro 1 re j en tout
cas extrêmement fort et plus largement
ce divorce que l'on sent qu'on le voit
dans l'ascension que l'on voit dans le
vote protestataire depuis si longtemps
et à chaque élection on se dit oh mais
c'est dingue ce vote protestataire et
après pendant cinq ans on oublie
évidemment qu'il va falloir se poser et
se regarder ça de près et quand
disons que mélenchon dans son succès au
1er tour c'est aussi parce que il
parlait de 6ème république parce qu'il
parlait de participation citoyenne et
parce qu'il parlait peut-être aussi
d'écologie ouais effectivement emmanuel
macron ça va être un des gros enjeux de
ce quinquennat de résorber cette
fracture démocratique d'autant que manu
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon et
évidemment ils vont chercher ce vote ils
vont chercher ces problématiques c'est
un défi très important mais en fait la
structuration politique aujourd'hui
creuse ce set trancher entre ces deux
france on est passé d'un système qui
était dominé par un clivage droite
gauche qui quand vous prenez le rpr le
ps qui était intéressant dans ses
parties c'est que vous aviez des
ouvriers vous habiller des cadres des
cadres dirigeants nous avait en fait
toutes les catégories sociales qui dans
chacun des partis de droite ou de gauche
étaient présents ce qui est imposé à ces
parties de faire un programme de
cohésion qui qui qui touchait à peu près
toutes les classes seraient un peu pour
tout le monde ce qui permettait à vous
faites une forme de deux d'unités là on
voit que ce clivage droite gauche en
2017 a été balayée remplacé par un
nouveau clivage entre un bloc populaire
qu'on voit cette sociologie des jaunes
et un bloc élitaire marine le pen étant
hégémonique chez les classes populaires
et emmanuel macron étant le champion de
ces de ce bloc élitaire
mondialisée pro-européen et si oui le
problème c'est que quand vous avez des
formations qui sont un peu je caricature
évidemment mais avec une seule
sociologie ça produit des programmes
pour cette sociologie là et du coup vous
avez en fonction des programmes en fait
d'aider chaque élection plutôt que
réconcilier plutôt que recoudre jette
une france l'une contre l'autre et c'est
très très visible dans la carte du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle mais aussi dans la
seconde dire que vous avez de moins en
moins de territoire mitigés ou en gros
c'était 40 51 vous avez des 65 % pour
marine le pen des 80% pour emmanuel
macron le problème c'est que d'année en
année on voit les passerelles entre ces
deux france s'écrouler on sait pas
comment les rôtis sais quoi et quand on
essaie de france il ya quand même une
nouvelle catégorie de population si
c'est les jeunes contre les vieux on a
quand même senti devenir très forte
pendant cette élection avec des jeunes
qui disait vous êtes en train de le
en l'air notre avenir
et ces jeunes dans les avions en colère
potentiellement aussi extinction
rébellion par exemple se sont beaucoup
des jeunes il ya une forme radicale
aussi de l'écologie aujourd'hui qui
émergent qui d'ailleurs s'est associé au
gilet jaune ponctuellement assez
régulièrement voilà donc je pense que
dans ces fractures
élitaire populaire il ya aussi jeune
dieu ça veut dire qu'un attention alors
le mouvement des jeunes n'est plus actif
et on voit moins ceci dit sont peut-être
à deux doigts il suffirait pas d'une
étincelle franck et repas mais est-ce
qu'un autre mouvement
pourrait voir le jour durant son
quinquennat temps la colère est forte
oui et justement peut-être avec des
ajouts de population qu'on ne
soupçonnait pas par exemple cette ces
jeunes qui qu'on a vu assez en colère s
est déterminé
[Musique]